new phone new intro let's get started
what's going on guys my name is David
Tommy and welcome back to the channel if
you're new here this is a channel where
we discuss all sorts of different tech
that you might be interested in so if
you haven't already make sure you smash
that subscribe button we're trying to
make it to a thousand subscribers before
the end of the year so today's video is
gonna be short sharp and sweet basically
it's the best phone that you can buy
right now in 2019 under 1000 American
dollars now the reason I'm doing this in
American dollars and not Australian
dollars is for the simple fact that 50%
of my audience right now is all from
America so you guys are asking for the
United States currency and well I'm
delivering at this time around if I'm
talking about today is the Samsung S 10
plus if you're going to go out and grab
it right now in Australia it's gonna
cost you about fifteen hundred dollars
and you can even find it for even less
if you buy it online and don't go direct
to retail stores if you're buying in
America it's well under the thousand
dollar price range so it's perfect for
anybody looking for an upgrade right now
in 2019 so why is this phone the best
phone under a thousand bucks well simply
put the cameras at the back are
incredible you get a three set camera
display with an ultra wide a wired and
standard code photo lens which makes
pretty much any photography experience
super simple and easy to capture it
doesn't matter if you're out there
taking real estate photos if you're
taking macro photos of plants you're
able to get pretty much pro grade 11
photos from this simple little
smartphone now if you haven't watched
any videos on the s10 plus then you
probably haven't realized that has an
ultrasonic fingerprint scanner in the
bottom of the glass so no buttons
whatsoever and you still have the
ability to unlock with your fingerprint
when your face isn't over the phone it
does also come with the face unlock
which is super convenient and very quick
as you can see in this video here now
also comes with some amazing specs 4k
video recording at 60 frames a second
and wireless power child sharing which
is an ultra
called feature that is going to just
take off for Samsung in the near future
now there is one thing that this phone
is lacking and that's 5g capabilities
now if you're going to be a troll and
drop some comments down below saying 5g
is the future yes you're right 5g is
going to be amazing but for the time
being in Australia in America even there
isn't that many 5g hotspots around and
you're not actually getting that much
capability out of your phone so if we
give it another four or five years then
chances are 5g is gonna be amazing
throughout the whole country and you're
actually gonna receive all these
benefits of purchasing 5g phone between
now and four or five years time you're
probably going to go through a couple
more phones one maybe two maybe three
depends how quickly your plan expires or
how quickly you go through phones but
that means you don't need to go out and
blow an extra five hundred two thousand
dollars on a 5g model for no reason now
last but not least the best feature
about this phone is simply the Samsung
decks to be able to connect this to a
little dock on your computer screen and
boot it up like a laptop is incredible I
personally believe that this is the
future of laptops especially with
Samsung dual folding screens technology
that's soon to hit the market again
after they fix up the little errors and
bugs they had in the past and that's it
from me guys I hope you enjoyed the
video I made sure it was short sharp and
sweet today because nobody wants to
watch a 20 minute video on the best
phone under a thousand bucks you guys
want the information I hope I gave it to
you smash that subscribe button and as
always I'll see you next Monday